do i think she's a factor
yeah of course do i think she's the soul
factor god no
no
if if it is that bad there's something
deeper within will that chooses to stay
in that relationship and that's the
thing that needs to be resolved
[Music]
what is happening there reject nation
greg and john here today got more big
willy things to talk about so i want to
talk about what just happened i know
we're a little bit late to it apologies
got a lot going on in the life as of
late and then uh i want to talk about
jada pinkett smith as well hot topic
there the devil woman as the internet
calls her keep her name out of your
mouth all right guys so will smith has
been banned from the oscars for 10 years
here's what's going on the board has
decided for a period of 10 years from
april 8th 2022 mr smith
uh shall not be promised we're going to
washington be permitted to attend any
academy events or programs in person or
virtually included but not limited to
the academy awards said i'm past
president david rubin and ceo don hudson
of smith's unacceptable and harmful
behavior we also hope this can begin a
time of healing and restoration for all
involved and impacted and of course they
said that we want to express our deep
gratitude to mr rock for maintaining his
composure under extraordinary
circumstances
that he did he doesn't get enough credit
i think we also want to thank our hosts
nominees presenters and winners for
their poise
and grace during our telecast this
action we're taking today in response to
will smith's behavior is a step towards
a larger goal of protecting the safety
of our performers and guests and
restoring trust
in the academy couple things to note i
still feel like in all things
considering it got off pretty easy at
least they didn't take his oscar away
you know yeah sure that and they
admitted a little bit of culpability and
how they did or did not handle the
situation and set an example and all
that stuff they act like it's the most
horrendous thing ever when they let the
camera roll on him and they kept cutting
back and forth to will to catch his
reaction throughout the night and when
it was his time for his speech oh man
they let him go on and on and on they
knew about them ratings and it's better
to ask for forgiveness and they cut to
the academy all standing and giving him
an applause so you know you're just like
yeah i'm sure at the time you were like
this is bad but
let's milk this simultaneously
let's see how this bad situation plays
out still be good ratings but then we'll
we'll apologize later so something to
note will smith can uh still get
nominated though so even though he's
banned he just can't attend any event
and he's not a member anymore but he can
still get nominated meaning he can still
potentially win an oscar which to me is
just insane how nuts would it be if will
smith actually won an oscar in this
10-year time frame would they allow that
to happen can you imagine if they let
will smith win an oscar and just the
kind of weird attention it would draw oh
yeah and then jada goes and accepts the
award
the devil woman's on stage i mean it's
kind of crazy because he's got that
oscar and while he should be proud of
that oscar it's a little nuts you know
usually when you have something that
level of memorabilia that award that
accolade set up somewhere in your house
or given to a family member every time
he sees that i just wonder will he not
be able to think about everything
horrible that has occurred following
that event right now at will smith's
house he is literally moving that thing
further and further and further from
himself until it's finally going to wind
up in an attic somewhere and it's just
not going to stop guilting him i mean
roman polanski managed to win while he
was uh scared of stepping into the
states for all the reasons he should be
scared will smith can definitely win
it'd be exciting to see that happen i
can imagine that also this ban can be
lifted somehow oh sure if he does enough
things to sway the court of public
opinion or if he does something
especially uh philanthropic or gives
back and so i mean he's always on social
media doing things so i'm sure he could
demonstrate something that you know the
academy loves a good story and a good
underdog i i don't know if 2032 will be
the next time we see
the academy awards let ezra miller take
a spot all right guys moving on here i
wanted to talk about jada pinkett smith
i'm not gonna talk uh heavily specific
but there's this clip that's been going
around circulating the web all over
again and before this clip even came out
the talks about
miss jada have have already been so
predominant but let's let's play this
clip for you guys really quick you know
stan perell is coming to the table she's
going to be at the red table
would you say she has been instrumental
in you and i redefining our relationship
i would say don't just start filming me
without asking me oh my goodness if you
confess
come help us again please
i'm still dealing with foolishness don't
no no she yeah because she don't just
would you say that she helped us heal
the hurts that we caused between one
another my social media presence is my
bread and butter okay so you can't just
use me for social media and not
you know don't just start wrong i'm
standing in my house
don't just start rolling
please watch a stare at the red table
because she's helped us a lot can't you
tell okay so uh after that been
circulating a lot you know
it's look it's not a good look for jade
because it's not gonna lie
for their relationship whatsoever
especially when talking about bringing
like a counselor or therapist on who's
helped them with their relationship part
of me was like i wonder if this is just
the driest form of comedy i've ever seen
i'm just gonna act like a sad child like
trying not to retaliate like the irony
of talking about a woman who's helped
her relationship out so much he's gonna
be on a red table and then you're
displaying marital communication
problems a part of me did wonder that it
doesn't read that way it does look like
a display of some type of narcissistic
controlling behavior in the form the
skies in the form of sarcasm and then
you know the jada pinkett smith has uh
done some pretty bad things
entanglements we call them entanglements
yeah to be safe also there's been you
know times where she's just the way
she's talked about will smith especially
in the bedroom has been quite insulting
seems to be a lot of like demeaning of
the man that he is and a lot of
disrespect why i want to talk about this
is a little bit different i find this a
whole
type of narrative that's been going
around that just seems like now that
will smith has apologized has he even
responded the academy awards he said
like a direct response i accept and
respect the academy's decision with
everywhere i see for the past week it's
been so much the target of everything
has been jada pink and smith i am not
here to defend jada pinkett smith i have
a however though i am not here to defend
jada pinkett smith i don't think the
solution though moving forward from the
actions that will smith has done is to
now make
jada pinkett smith the target yeah i
don't agree with this look the
impressions that everyone has of their
relationship i'm right there with you
guys i am i'm totally like the
relationship seems toxic it does seem
like there's it's probably a very
emotionally abusive relationship it
doesn't seem healthy this is all the
impressions like i don't know what
they're like behind the scenes could be
not as bad could be way worse than more
you know known what we've been privy to
so far but this idea that an order for
will smith to rebound the solution has
to cut off jada pinkett smith maybe
maybe for him to heal the ideas to get
out of that relationship maybe i don't
think though that him going up on stage
slapping chris rock
yelling at the top of his lungs that's
not jada pinkett smith's fault is it a
factor of a lot of repression that
probably played into the situation maybe
but the thing is will smith is a grown
ass man and he's obviously a wise adult
as well is he in a toxic relationship it
seems like it sure but he makes his own
choices and he made the choices that day
so i don't think the solution moving
forward is to start putting all the
blame trying to make jada pinkett smith
the worst thing in the world and will
smith would totally have all his [ __ ]
under control if he wasn't with jada
pinkett smith end of the day
you don't know that you can't transfer
that culpability it just doesn't work
that way like she gave him that look and
that look suggests things that everyone
has been speculating supported by other
videos like the one you just saw even if
you take that prompt as well she wanted
him to do something he could have chosen
a bunch of other things half of which he
still did anyway yeah so yeah it's not
like she controls literally controls his
mind and i feel like that's a way some
people like to portray situations like
this but ultimately yeah it is up to him
as to whether or not he allows that kind
of influence to get in his way and to
cause him to make a choice that he had
to have known would be a little bit
muddy in terms of everyone's reception
once it was over with that transference
of culpability it doesn't make sense you
could totally fathom that if he goes to
therapy and he's talking he's like well
i've had all this like built up thing
with jada and i feel like less of a man
when i'm around her and i was trying to
prove i'm a man and i feel like she
still thinks about tupac or whatever
[ __ ] people want to say right like
maybe sure that doesn't matter it was
still will smith's choice it was still
him who did it you still got to act
right
in public at work and he still chooses
if jade is the devil he still chooses to
be with the devil out of that
relationship if it is to the point where
you can't make your own decisions with a
clear mind you can't just say it's all
her you can't just like like uh you know
strip away the sins of will smith by
slowly putting it on the woman in his
relationship autonomy he is still
choosing to be in the relationship if it
is as bad as everyone is saying it is
sure okay maybe he won't heal until then
he's choosing that he has more power
than her in hollywood
the motivations for some of these
speculations come from in the first yes
yeah it's that discrepancy of status
that's got to play a role in a
relationship like this i'll leave it at
this do i think she's a factor
yeah of course do i think she's the soul
factor
god no
no
if if it is that bad there's something
deeper within will that chooses to stay
in that relationship and that's the
thing that needs to be resolved all
right guys
well are you team jade or team will yeah
where are you at
give your best diss in the comments
i think we can stop talking about this
for hopefully 10 more years every time
we record one of these we say this
all right well thanks for being here
all right these are [ __ ] weird i know
see you guys
[Music]